hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video guys as
usual we're gonna go through amc jme
press action we're gonna go uh through
triple q press action as well we are
having guys some
bad things happening on the us 10 new
yield and the dxy so we're going to go
through that as well and we're going to
try to understand what is happening with
those markets that are selling again
today
uh and try to see what can happen next
so let's get into it
all right guys
so
not a good day again i mean not a bad
day uh but not a good day either
amc down two percent gme down almost
eight percent guys nasdaq pretty much
flatish and we having guys some breakout
confirmation in the weekly time frame
uh that we had already last
friday but today we are making new eyes
on the us 10 years
we are almost at three this is
not a good signal
so let's see what can happen next year
so first amc
amc on the first time frame we are still
in this descending wedge so once again a
descending wedge can last for long it's
not because you're on a descending wedge
with some bullish divergences as we're
having here that uh the reversal is uh
coming right away but it's just an
environment where it could happen any
time
so we are monitoring that right now as
you can see we got again today rejected
on this trend line
uh that is moving lower every day so you
know
i don't know what can wha what would
happen here but i'm looking for a move
above this level with increase in volume
for now we're not having it bears and
control on the short and medium term
um
on the long term as well guys
as can be seen we are in a massive
correction that is you know
just going lower
as you can see with the strength line
so bears and control guys that's the
reality of uh what is happening
and and we are waiting for a bullish
sign
that could help bulls to gather their
strengths and to take some ground on the
upside and you know come back to this
area where
it would be dangerous for bears but yes
for now we're far from that
and what is happening on the rest of the
market is not
good so jimmy jamie dropping brutally
today
uh we have identified that uh the 130
125 level was an area of support
we considered it here for four days as
you can see here guys just like we did
here before
and today we are dropping we clearly
broke out on the downside i don't see
volume increase so
you know it's not because you don't have
a volume increase that uh it will not go
lower it just means that
it's going to be easier when the
situation will
be better for bulls to take back control
uh but for now booze are not trying
anything they're not buying you know
there there is no activity so we are
dropping on low volume and we can drop
lower
uh the next support level is
105
do we have anything else that could help
bulls to organize on the downside
i'm trying to see
if i have some trend line maybe
no not really
this is not helping
no i don't have anything before 105 so
this is the the next support guys
i'm afraid we're going there
um
i hope i'm wrong but i'm afraid we're
going to 105 and maybe even to
the lows
it's not totally looking good guys uh
we need once again
the
the sentiment to shift on the global
market so what is the situation still
the same
narrative here
we are in a slowing economy we are not
able to lower the rates as we usually do
as the fed is usually doing in this kind
of situation
they cannot lower the rates because
inflation is here guys
we can feel it i mean i feel it even
when i go to the grocery shop to buy you
know food chicken meat whatever
everything is more expensive
vegetables everything you you the bread
i'm french so you know i can i'm buying
bread very often the baguette and it's
more expensive everything is more
expensive because the community prices
are going up
because there is some issues in the
supply chain
because of kovid first then because of
war
um and and yeah this is impacting uh the
price of creating things and
whatever you know food or cars or
computers everything is going to be more
expensive because of this supply chain
issues and because of higher
uh price of commodity that i use to
create all these things so this is the
situation we are in
this is not a good situation
and the fed must fight this inflation so
to fight this inflation
they need to slow the economy so to slow
the economy they increase rates and as
you guys know we have
a historic uh
high level of debt
everywhere in the world
so
rising
rates i mean
putting the rates higher
is gonna create some issues for all the
countries all the companies that have
that have high levels of debt
and
let me first finish this analysis then
i'm going to tell you what i think might
happen in triple q
but as those companies need dollars to
pay back the debt you can see the rush
for the dollar and i told you guys to
monitor this uh dxy which is the dollar
index
uh as you know a fear indicator fear and
it's not only a few indicators also
so of course it's showing that there is
fear that people rush for the dollar to
pay back the debt
uh because the most of the debt in the
world had been made denominated in
dollars
uh but it's also
making it more difficult more difficult
for this
companies or countries that have you
know a debt
in dollars but that use a foreign
currency to pay back the debt so it's a
double
signal that is not good
for
the equity market and as i told you guys
the u.s 10-year yield
very important to watch we were in a 40
years downtrend and we are breaking out
guys so it's been the third
week we are trading above this trend
line
and it's the first time we reach three
so i can tell you that this level is a
level that a lot a lot of investors have
in mind and
everybody is going to talk about the
fact that the u.s 10-year yield reached
three
maybe we're gonna have a selling
reaction here
i do hope we have it because if we don't
have it if we keep going higher which is
for now the most
likely scenario
um
this once again is not good for the
equity market because uh the u.s tenu
yield is the expected rate of return of
the equity market so
the higher it is the more competitive
it's going to be for companies i mean
the tougher is going to be for companies
to beat this and so the less competitive
the equity market is going to be for
investors compared to the bond market to
the
treasury
treasury
yields
so this is the situation where in guys
and it's not good
dx y above 103 us 10 yield above 285
triple two now uh i didn't take a
position today once again i'm
pretty flatish uh on my positions i'm
i'm even make a little bit of money when
the market is dropping some slightly
short
uh i'm trying to increase this short
position
um
but
today we were discussing that in my
discord
you know
there was a trade to do i didn't do it
because
you know
it's there is a lot of activities it's
not easy to make safe trades uh in this
situation but here
uh 3 18 was the last support and today
it acted very well as resistance we
opened we went higher and then we got
rejected but let's be honest we could
have very well come here and here i
would have taken a short position all
right i don't want to sell on the way
down
as i am already short but for those who
are not short it's i mean
it's better to reduce positions not
financial advice but at least not
i would not buy the dip if i had already
a long position i'm having a slightly
short position i'm not gonna buy this
dip i'm gonna wait here 280 guys because
i don't know exactly how but we'll
probably go there we can do some elliot
wave theory here
because we are
in um
wxy correction
so the wxy correction should happen with
an abc right
so we should have here
an abc
so
you see at some point we gotta have a
rebound all right a b wave
so i don't know exactly how it's gonna
be guys all right maybe something like
that
okay that's one scenario i'm not saying
you know it's the
it's
the way things will happen but it's
something like this probably
so we're gonna have and a waves usually
develop in five waves right so we're
gonna have something like that so this
is
so it's not easy to know if this is a
one two or you can do one two
three four five
maybe
or you could do
one two three four five it doesn't
change much
we're gonna have i think a small
pullback before one more leg down coming
soon all right so this
is gonna be a nice opportunity to take
some protection or to build a short
position then
uh
here of course
it's hard to say if we're gonna go
right away
to here i don't think so
but it's possible
but here there is a long position to
build it's dangerous to buy here
uh and then here maybe the b wave
we're gonna need to analyze all of that
if here we have volume or not in this b
wave
then we're probably going to have if we
don't have volume sorry in this rebound
that will probably happen maybe here
maybe even before
if we rebound without volume i mean we
never have big volume in moves up on
triple q but we can still have some
decent volume and strong moves up or
small moves up with very small volume so
this is what you're going to pay
attention to exactly like we did here
guys all right and this is the reason
why here i took a short position because
here
i mean
we move we had one day with big volume
but most of the days were with uh very
low volume
so this is what we're gonna try to to
see and the moves were small all right
here we moved quite strongly at the
beginning but then we were just grinding
higher right so this was the situation
for a reversal so here we're going to
try to monitor the same thing and see if
we have this c wave that can happen
later or not uh but guys as long as the
u.s 10-year yield is above this 285
three level
consider that we're gonna keep dropping
all right we're gonna keep dropping and
i don't see
a bullish scenario possible
with this u.s 10 year yield above three
so if
we keep going higher here
then
whatever
pullback we have on the upside because
it's a pullback on the way down so
whatever corrective move on the upside
we have here it's going to probably be
sold because investors are going to
unwind the long positions asset managers
like i told you guys banks
you know all the professional investors
they will offload the equity positions
uh if this u.s 10-year yield stays
around these levels and even more if it
goes higher
so this is what we need to pay attention
to
once again guys the situation is not
great
for now so as long as the situation is
like that
stay light lightly invested
it's not a situation to me to buy the
dip
um
if we have some very strong moves down
then yes
all right so around if triple two loses
you know 10 10 12 percent
uh so for amc maybe around 13
or on the upside breakout
uh ngme around 85 or 105 you know even
105 seems early to buy guys
uh i would here just once again try to
secure as much as possible the positions
uh for those who want to don't don't
have short position try to take some
short position on the way up on triple q
uh using s triple two for example so
that at least you know
you
you survive if we go lower because i'm
afraid we will
um
and yeah just stay safe guys not
financial advice but i think we're not
in a nice environment for the coming
weeks maybe coming month
this is the situation to me um
i'm gonna keep updating you guys i'm
sorry i don't have good news today
um but once again we might have a
rebound coming soon so
let's keep hope let's keep faith and we
can still manage to get out of the
situation if the growth
help us to um to fight inflation so this
is what we're trying to do let's see if
we can do it guys i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys